louis xiv règne sur la cité royale ou
plutôt la gare de versailles chantiers
derrière ces 98 panneaux un programme
immobilier 120 mètres de palissade
réalisé pendant un mois par deux street
artist won et fit cause raconte
l'histoire de la ville de versailles du
street art inspiré de gravure ancienne
athlète hors highlight chamond j'essaie
de mettre en valeur les plus belles
heures de son histoire d'amour avec king
of corse par exemple nous avons peint le
roi bien sûr on s'est approprié des
scènes
la ville de versailles la brassière
lavoisier colbert quelques personnes
célèbres et mon art est basé sur les
tradition byzantine et grecs parce que
je suis grecque
j'aime l'histoire et la mythologie des
créations uniquement au pinceau débuté
au mois de janvier au sein même de la
ville
les deux artistes internationaux sont
les invités du collectif qu'est 36
donner de la vie aux chantiers d'y
apporter de la couleur de de faire un
lien avec la ville aussi est d'amener de
l'art dans les endroits justement de
chantier c'est un endroit très
fonctionnel à ces polluants personne ne
sait vraiment ce qui se passait nous
c'est d'apporter une communication une
nouvelle communication
la fresque sera visible face à la gare
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mai avant
d'être disciplinés dans versailles